but let's go
I'm talking about
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
to the body than to the Head
thank you and Creed staggers back
buddy buddy buddy to the body trading
shots pouring with his jab Reed looks to
land one big shot
that way
[Applause]
Daddy get up
get update
come on baby
stats
[Applause]
Creed just got up like a man possessed
but the referee is dusting cream
[Applause]
and the action begins again that's the
heart of the champion yes his daddy's
heart I'll tell you that much more work
to do for countless body shots
stitch has done a great job over that
right eye but now the left eye is looks
like it's almost shut close enough
it's okay
I'm good you're good I'm good all right
I'm taking a lot of punishment to both
the body and the head left eye
completely closed no let me see the eye
give him away
she'll be right show me your eye Donuts
how many fingers
how many fingers how many of them is
four and again
two
time in all right breathe through your
mouth deep breath kid people you are up
on the cards you're winning this you are
gonna win this but just keep smart and
keep away from me he's going to sleep
this time he's going out this round I
should have stopped it's going to be fun
I'm stopping this one now don't okay let
me finish
I gotta prove it who what
I'm not a mistake
really I never got a chance to think of
Paul for helping me out after Mickey
died but it's nothing compared to what
you
you taught me how to fight again and I'm
gonna go home and I'm gonna fight this
thing but if I fight I want you to fight
too I want you to go across this ring
and knock that son of a down can
you do it
that's it I'm Gonna Knock that son of a
down I know you are you know what
because you're a Creed and I love you
kid
[Music]
ding
round 12 begins virtually no one outside
of Adonis Creed's family and group of
friends would ever had expected to see
him in a 12th round against Pretty Ricky
conlon and trading shots as they come to
these last three minutes
upstairs
you can't believe hard right hand by
Colin come on double sister they're
trading shots and the kind of back and
forth action that most of us didn't
expect to see
[Music]
Reed getting hit with some hard jocks
but landing Summit Zone and Adonis is
firing back another pitch battle between
the two Warriors
green spins puts the champ in the corner
buddy buddy throwing body shots like
he's Rocky Balboa going upstairs like
he's Apollo Creed
closing second to the fight
okay
that's what I'm talking about Conlin is
down that is the first time in his
career he's been on the canvas you
cannot be Saved by the Bell on the 12th
and final round
six dramatic countries
survives the 12th round what a finish if
that round goes another 30 seconds we
may have a new Champion an unforgettable
fight on an unforgettable night he's no
longer just the namesake of Apollo Creed
he's the living embodiment ladies and
Gentlemen The Round of Applause for
these two Warriors in the ring for the
winner by split precision
and still The Undefeated
[Applause]
been 10 seconds longer 10 seconds longer
[Music]
I'm gonna get some you're the future to
this division we have our name of Pride
respect we need something to try to turn
this fight around
foreign
[Applause]
trying to end it
right here
[Applause]
seemingly frustrated he was close to
finishing the fight
you've got to throw me something if not
I'm gonna stop it
couldn't fight oh good
good I'm calling this fight don't
call this
to nobody look at you your ribs look
like they broke
she goes but foreign
ers
please
now as we go to round three Adonis
Greene has been beaten up and bloodied
by an avalanche of power shots from Ivan
Drago in the first two rounds and we'll
see how much Adonis Creed has left out
she tries to stay alive in the fight
stop the fight dangerous wings and
Dragons
still putting huge pressure on the bike
attack
oh and with a devastating shot to the
rib cage
now here we go with round ten of what
has become a war of attrition Drago
seemingly ahead on the scorecards but
Creed refusing to back
read using whatever he has left in the
tank
[Music]
and down goes Creed again and this could
be the end of the fight
ah
damn
foreign
[Music]
struggle
what a wild turn of events come on
[Applause]
[Music]
it's still swinging Max Reed continuing
to connect and discipline
gym I don't think Drago has anything
less but he refuses to give up
[Applause]
[Music]
and that's it it's awesome
because 200 grows in the towel at the
goddess Creed defends his title defends
his name creates his own legacy he is
still the heavyweight champion of the
world
and the Russian crowd is standing and
cheering for the American fighter
all right
[Music]
back up everybody
foreign
[Music]
good morning
it's your time
thank you
foreign
[Music]